for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
in 1924 louis de broglie thought if
light which is energy that was
classically viewed to be a wave if light
can behave like a particle then perhaps
matter which was classically viewed to
be particle like can behave as a wave so
using three equations we're going to
figure this out okay we're going to see
equals lambda nu which we saw before
speed of light equals lambda the
wavelength times the frequency and then
energy equals Planck's constant times
the frequency and equals MC squared
which is one of Einstein's one of the
things I incise famous for his famous
equation relating energy to mass and the
speed of light squared so what we're
going to do here is we're going to use
these three equations to find a new
equation that we'll see in a moment okay
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to take C equals lambda nu
and divide both sides by wavelength and
we will get nu equals C over lambda so
we just solved basically for new and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take this we're going to take
what we got here for new and we're going
to plug that in here we're going to plug
that in for new in the e equals H nu
equation so what that'll give us is that
will give us energy equals H times C
over lambda all we do is plug in C over
lambda in for new so now we have energy
e equals HC over lambda now what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
equation and just solve it for
wavelength right solve for lambda
so that'll give us lambda equals HC over
e now we've solved for wavelength here
and from here what we're going to do is
we're going to place that e with MC
squared okay so we're going to replace e
with MC squared because e equals MC
squared and then we get lambda equals HC
over MC squared now we can cancel one of
these sees one see here one see here and
that'll give us lambda equals h / MC so
the wavelength is going to equal
Planck's constant over mass times the
speed of light but now what de Broglie
was doing basically is his truck he was
trying to develop an equation that could
express the wavelength of a particle so
and and the particle is not necessarily
moving at the speed of light so what he
did was he replaced see with the speed
of the particle okay so we're going to
replace C with you which is going to
represent the particle speed and so we
get there as lambda equals H over mu and
that might have seemed like a mess but
basically what de brouilly did here is
he developed this equation which he
which is basically for the de Broglie
wavelength okay which we see here so the
de Broglie wavelength is lambda which of
course is equal to wave length is equal
to H over mu so H is Planck's constant
which we know to be six point six to six
times ten to the negative 34 jules time
seconds m is going to be the particle in
question it's going to be it's its mass
maybe the particles mass specifically in
kilograms and the reason has to be in
kilograms is because has to cancel with
a jewel unit because 1 jul 1 jul equals
1 kilogram
times meters squared per second squared
can't express how important this is to
remember so the particles Massa needs to
be in kilograms you is the particle
speed and specifically in meters per
second again for the units to cancel and
then lambda is is going to be the
particles de Broglie wavelength in
meters so what's happening here is de
Broglie basically measure or he made an
equation that allows you to find the
wavelength of a particle which is kind
of weird right because that's that's
assuming that matter is acting like a
wave okay so one thing to notice here in
this equation is that things with large
masses right massive objects let's
artisan in white massive objects which
are things with of course a large mass
have very short wavelengths because if
you increase the mass here the
wavelength will get smaller as you're
dividing by a bigger number so large
large objects things with large masses
have short wavelengths so let's use this
equation it for a brightness problem
here so if we're asked to find the
wavelength of an electron moving at a
speed of 2.0 times 10 to the 6 meters
per second the mass of electron is given
as 9.1 1 times 10 to the negative 31
kilograms okay find the wavelength so
that's lambda there they wants to find
lambda so the equation is already solved
for lambdas we don't have to manipulate
it with an electron moving at a speed of
this so this this here is you and it's
already in meters per second so we don't
have to change that and the mass of an
electron here is is the mass of the
object so massive electron that's going
to be our m and that is here and it's
already in kilograms so we want to
change anything there so for this we
just plug and chug H is a constant
that's Planck's constant so it's 6 point
6 26 x 1080 34 now I'm not going to
write Jules x seconds I'm going to write
it as
one kilogram times meters squared per
second squared times seconds because
that whole portion there is a jewel so
kilogram times meters squared per second
squared times seconds okay and again
that's because this part here is a jewel
right those are the units for jewel so
that's H on top and on the bottom here
we're going to have the mass in
kilograms so that'll be 9.11 times 10 I
got 31 kilograms and the particle speed
is given to us as 2.0 times 10 to the 6
meters per second okay so now how these
units going to cancel just to break it
down what's going to happen here is that
we're going to put all the units that
are on top here and then I'll even sit
on the bottom here so kilograms is on
top in the numerator so it goes there so
is meters squared so that goes there and
so is seconds so put that there now
second square here is at the bottom side
to be sure to put that in the
denominator kilograms here is on the
bottom so i'm going to write kilograms
in the denominator meters here is in the
bottom as well but the second is in the
denominator in the denominator so that's
10 this is basically 1 over 1 over s
which means that this s is going to come
up here and the second squared here from
from the numerator is going down so it's
going to be down here so how do these
units cancel the kilograms cancel one of
these meters cancel and then these
seconds times seconds on top cancel the
second squared and all we're left with
is meters so we get the wavelength in
meter so if we multiply that all out and
all those units cancel we get three
point six four times ten to the negative
10 meters so what is this this is the
wavelength of a particle specifically
the wavelength of an electron moving at
this particular speed this is the
wavelength the de Broglie wavelength of
an electron moving at this speed right
so it's the wavelength of a particle
okay which is kind of a weird concept
right particles act behaving as waves
okay so electrons do have a wave nature
which is kind of crazy okay also since
we're talking about the wave nature of
electrons these two these two people
Davisson and Germer these two they
showed that electrons have diffraction
patterns and typically waves are have
different diffraction patterns particles
don't so diffraction patterns have if
something has to fashion patters or
shows diffraction patterns it's that's a
wave property so electrons have a wave
nature and if we could find their
wavelength using this equation so hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying